[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the chest 24
banter blitz session uh between anish
giri and magnus carlsen
and if you've been following the morphe
saga you know that in those days
uh you know morphe and low intel for
example sold their disputes
in a local bar or maybe a library but
now in 2020
uh disputes are dissolved over uh not
over the board but
online and this is one of the games from
their match it wasn't a lo
a very long match but this is one of the
games i thought it was
very exciting as uh it just shows that
anyone like anyone can fall into a very
nasty trap
so uh without further ado let's check it
out gary with the white pieces
opens with e4 with e5 by magnus
at knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to c4 so the italian game is on the
board we have bishop to c5
and now some of you may know that there
is a really really great move
in this position possible uh some would
say even even the best
uh that is the move b4 which is the
evans gambit
uh unfortunately it was not played in
this game uh so here gary goes for c3 he
goes into the main line of the joko
piano
we have d6 by magnus and d3 now we have
knight to f6 and just
castles uh and here h6 uh we always
mentioned that knight to g for going
after
the f2 pawn really doesn't do all that
much and
the the rook is still on f1 so here a6
the most
popular move bishop b6 castles all very
nice options magnus goes for h6 which is
not the
uh the most popular move but it is very
popular uh with
knight bd2 the standard joko piano stop
shifting the knights to f1 from where
you can go to g3 uh we have castles by
magnus and now
rook to e1 and rook to e8
and finally b4 so it's a good move but
some uh four moves too late
uh we have bishop to b6 and now a4 and
here
uh the position has been reached before
the unknown move is a6 here gawain jones
played it in 2010
but here magnus goes for a5 and it is as
of move tended we have a completely new
game
so making room for the bishop making
sure y doesn't trap it now we have b5
challenging the knight and the knight
back to e7 so now
you can shoot the knight to g6 have a
nice outpost for your knight
on f4 you can bring the other knight to
f4 as well so all is
always very nice here and here uh now
that um
uh the rook has been developed queen b3
uh makes sense you go after the f7 pawn
and the magnus needs to waste the move
uh to guard the pawn again so rook to f8
and now
d4 uh challenging the the central e5
pawn
so magnus defends it uh while
remaneuvering the knight and then now
comes h3
gary takes away the g4 square from
magnus's pieces he doesn't want to allow
some very natural development
knight to h5 like we mentioned uh going
for that
f4 outpost and now bishop to f1 by gary
the bishop on f1
will add uh additional protection to the
uh to the kingside pawns we have queen
to f6
uh and with this queen to f6 move the
fun really starts here magnus has
a triple attack on the d4 pawn by the
queen by the pawn and by the bishop
uh and giri sets a deadly trap here he
plays queen to d1
and now it seems obvious like what's
happening here the knight
is undefended like you want to move the
knight and pick up the knight
but magnus says nope not really because
captures captures and
now i just capture and magnus wins upon
uh or does he
that that is the question what magnus
thought giri would play here
is just knight captures queen captures
and he cannot
grab the knight uh because the rook on
a1
would be hanging so here after bishop
captures on d4 magnus missed gary's idea
here
and uh well you most probably won't so
feel free to pause the video
and win this game for gary while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh
preventing the queen from attacking the
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's
e5 and now you see the point
now the point is that uh well the queen
no longer guards the bishop and the
problem is if you capture here
with the uh pawn then just knight
captures pawn captures and the queen no
longer attacks the rook and now it's a
free knight queen captures on h5 and
gary wins
so that's one thing that can happen
after e5 another thing which is
way cooler is what happens after bishop
captures on e5
well here you just capture it and after
knight captures
then you play queen captures on h5 uh
now you go
knight to f3 with check opening up the
queen's
attack to the rook and after for example
knight captures on f3
queen captures on a1 now you get bishop
captures
on h6 here for example and uh everything
just falls apart for black he's down
material he's
completely lost for example queen goes
back bishop g5 you have a a knight and
bishop for a rook
and you have the attack you're just
completely winning here
so none of the moves are actually good
for for magnus here uh which means that
the d4 pawn was never really up for
grabs
so here uh we have bishop captures on f2
uh a last resort attempt for magnus uh
we have
uh king captures uh as the king was in
check and
now knight captures on e5 uh rook to a3
by geary adding another
defender to the third rank also
preparing to bring the king back and
then
the rook can come into play and now
bishop to f5
uh adding more more more pieces here
king to g1
now the king can finally move and here
with bishop to g6 for example
the game uh still some somewhat
continues however
magnus played rook 8 e8 here and
again giri manages to trick him because
here what carlson is uh
thinking uh for example captures
captures and then
uh if you go for this uh knight here
for example first rook captures queen
captures and now if you go for this
queen captures on h5
uh we can even show it you can play
queen to c5 check and pick up the bishop
here however
uh giri tricks him again so this is a
game full of uh
full of girish fishing soon here he
plays knight to c4
and now there is no queen c5 check
picking up the bishop and you don't
really have a good move here the queen
is under attack
the knight is under attack and there is
nothing to be done here
so here magnus played uh queen to c5
with check
but uh in order uh for you not to lose
any tempe by moving the king and then
allowing the knight back into the game
bishop to e3 of course uh which tempo
the queen is under attack queen to b4
and now it's uh it's a free knight queen
captures an h5 so gary grabs it we have
bishop to e6 now
uh hoping to remove the defender of the
rook but here gary goes bishop d2
again uh kicks the queen away from the
attack uh on the rook on a3
queen to b1 and here just ripped the c3
and it was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned the game on move 28
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh he's down two pieces and it's
it would be pointless to continue here
uh so
uh he resigned and uh this game went to
geary this is the only game geary one
actually but i decided to show this one
as
it it was just very nice featured that
very nice move
but the end result was five and a half
to one and a half for magnus who wins
the match and uh goes to the final
uh to face lebanon who defeated
alexander grishop
uh so yeah but it's very interesting i
checked out all the games
and i really thought magnus would
challenge gary to a nice uh
nice french defense as gear is all about
the the french defense now you know with
his chestable course and everything
uh but magnus did not play e4 in in a
single game
so that's a bit of a shame but uh what
are you going to do
and also if you are uh if you're still
not following our
newly created account for the for our
newly uh well not newly but almost
published uh chess manga slash comic
slash
web series uh do check it out it's the
first thing in the description below
that you will see
it's a twitter page of our age of kai'sa
uh twitter account where you can you
know follow stuff ask questions
and learn a little bit more before the
actual uh
chapter one is published tomorrow so
yeah uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
david kimura andreas
uh ivy and uh nicolas kaifa and ivan
sterling uh
last time i said even i don't know if
it's ivan or even but uh
either way uh thank you all for your
contribution i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the good
stuff checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day